oder ist schon voll für gewachsene das
wird richtig geil mein grundstück
gestellt
ja dann kenne ich meine angst von khg
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft hexe auf dem hero server und
zwar habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
einfach weiterhin noch mal im single
links magen hat grade immens geknüpft
sorry dass ich so oft demand sagen tut
mir leid hatte co eine goldene ach das
ist ja das ist die goldene feder small
hat ein kleines herz bridge sampling ein
bisschen was presley direkten setzlinge
werde ich wahrscheinlich gleich mal an
pflanzen wie ich mich fühle wird gleich
wieder nacht annehmen könnte alles noch
pflanzliche jemand papier gesetzlichen
und zwar richtig dass hier ein bisschen
was ich will ja nicht dass hier ich
möchte eigentlich nicht mehr weit ich
wollte eigentlich in wald aber da sind
ja jetzt hier zander und kohle gegangen
deswegen konnten weder gar nicht hin
aber das war nicht mein wunsch dahin
aber wir haben das natürlich
demokratisch abgestimmt von möchte ich
doch gar nicht mich gegen aufwenden
gegen das system gegen das system der
demokratie das natürlich alles schön und
gut aber ich möchte mich hier wenigstens
ein bisschen so mein haus herum so ein
bisschen natur haben nicht nur steppe
kann ich überhaupt jetzt alle mit links
machen
noch habe ich immer noch viel zu viel
auch wohl auf dem netz laden schon
wieder packen wir das eigentlich auch
mal eben ganz kurz machen und zwar hier
alles einfach abreißen so also wie
gesagt heute eine kleine bau folge muss
auch mal sein tut mir leid ihm freunde
letzte folge auch schon wolfsbau folge
deswegen möchte ich das jetzt so schnell
durchziehen wie es geht damit wir danach
in dungeon können oder mit anderen
aufnehmen kann was da wieder mal witzig
wird hörspiel und übrigens wollte dass
er alles außerdem in diesem holz bauen
und in den anderen habe ich mich ja
vorhin verbaut fest ich könnte quasi da
kann man alles ab
essen außer die fenster obwohl ich auch
eigentlich die dicken fenster blöcke
immer noch besser findet diese komischen
glasscheiben
ich weiß nicht das ist meine meinung ihr
könnt mir mal eure meinung schreiben was
findet ihr besser normales glas oder
dieses hier was ich hier gesehen habe
und dann können wir dann eine kleine
umfrage machen in den kommentaren
das heißt ihr dürft euch jetzt alle
gegeneinander betteln oder alt ist
minecraft dem neues mannschaft das ja
auch mal bis auf einige meinen minecraft
ist kein minecraft mehr die ansicht
hatte ich ja damals auf mittlerweile
finde ich aber dass minecraft auch in
der gewisse richtung geht eine sehr gute
richtung weil zeit einfach echt sehr
cool wirkt mittlerweile so mit neuem
text und farbiger wolle was ich mir echt
schon lange gewünscht hat alle stars
dein ernst von den star war was mir echt
schon lange gewünscht diese farbige
wolle
fabian leben dass ich endlich bessere
wolle farben gibt ich dachte mir dann
immer so dass man das so machen kann
dass oder machen könnte das eventuell
dann die gefärbte wollen nochmal färben
muss wenn wir zum beispiel rote wolle
hat noch mit weißer wolle färben dass
sie dann eventuell aus last mehr aus
bläst aus plastik ausgelassen
allerdings war vater von der fall und
der schweiz also hinzugefügt also mir
ist es egal es ist auf jeden fall schön
das ist jetzt dass ich finde minecraft
geht in die richtige richtung
natürlich jetzt ein thema was kann
schnell war schon tausend mal besprochen
wurde
aber eure meinung wird noch nie glaube
ich so richtig intensiviert nachgefragt
wie ich das jetzt gemacht hab also ich
würde das echt interessieren auf welcher
seite ihr dasteht und ja jetzt ist ja
auch battlefield 4 letztes rausgekommen
und wenn es ins creed for black flag und
kann ich jetzt noch nichts zu sagen ich
möchte dass in zukunft nötig sagen so
herausgekommen weil diese folge kommt
wahrscheinlich erst eine woche alte
sieht echt geil aus ich finde dann
hosting geil oder soll ich das darum
bloß all das sieht viel besser aus
eigentlich nicht das aus kommen lassen
oder ich bin immer so weit vom mikro weg
wenn ich hier drin ist es viel besser
alle single oder soll ich mal da unten
nämlich die cobblestone schon ganz gut
aus dicken brocken tiefen scheiße
was ist das denn jeder einfach runter
mal schauen was wieder hatten eine
druckplatte das im raum dass wir auch
gut rüber schauen was wir haben
geben sie einfach gegangen gegraben die
haben sich doch nicht wirklich dass
links punkte
diese echt so ranzig er hätte es ist so
heftig dass solche roadsters deren
grundstücke ich weiß gar nicht was ist
mit ärzten ab und bekommen wie der
steuerung komplett ineinander
das ist hier mit ärzten wie sieht
eigentlich aus wenn ich jetzt nicht im
regal ich habe ich habe eben diesen
komischen kaktus kappe auf dem kopf da
so ein kaktus
das haben wir den scheiß das haben diebe
schon alles aus diesem ganzen festung
das haben die nie im leben irgendwie
bekommen oder sich gemacht niemals
vincent und modellbau das so lassen oder
so ist echt ne blöde entscheidung mehr
so dietz weiter sagt kulas also alles in
einer farbe ist aber dass ich auch cool
aus wenn ich mache das aus denkt macht
das aus wenn ich das so machen
intel kommt da komme ich so koppel stone
ja wohl was könnte dann reden mit euch
deutschen einkaufen in der stadt
bisschen shoppen dann wie gesagt dmx hab
ich mir geholt
ich bin ja nicht tutorial ich möchte
eigentlich keinen hall jetzt machen aber
da er sehr viele weibliche zuschauer
irgendwie letzter zeit dazu gekommen
sind
man sieht das ja immer ein google
analytics übrigens viele leute meinen
ich habe irgendwie jetzt diese krankheit
dass man immer wackelt oder so habe ich
nicht aber ich bin immer mit meinem fuß
am wackeln deswegen sie das mal so aus
ich kann damit auch so einfach aufhören
total stable kämen hier machen
ich bin halt immer wackeln weil ich
immer irgendwie in bewegung sein muss
sport machen so was halt
deswegen bin ich dann noch mehr wackeln
als dann einfach schwer umzusetzen aber
auch in der schule immer
täglich alle sitzen so stöhr um luca
wackelt na gut so hier kommt dann noch
etwas hin
hier kommt dann einfach in unseren
eigenen reihen also ich denke was ich
will dich nicht haben
er gibt mir einfach was anderes der
blöde pizza natürlich noch ein paar hin
dann habe ich wieder ein bisschen den
wir noch kein jahr schoki durch weiße
aus angst vor der nacht um gespielt
sondern brav schön schlafen schlafen
schlafen simon schlafen schlafen jemand
mein job hat angst vor der dunkelheit
hier geht's dann so lange geht es dann
soll man das schon voll für gewachsene
das wird richtig geil mein grundstück
durchgang dann kenne ich meine angst von
trotzki müssen sich paaren fleck so da
wollte ich komplett glas hin machen aber
ich weiß nicht
hier muss ich ja trotzdem eigentlich ein
feiner dahin machen damit das nicht so
einfach so aufhört das glas aber ich hab
das viel zu niedrig gemacht dann kann
ich auch eigentlich schon mal ein
bisschen sand gleich ingo farben gehen
da sich sand hier braucht man dafür nur
normales krise
gemüse da ja keine ahnung glaub ich
glaube ja schon wie bei hunden mit
fleisch hat die kommen jetzt allgemein
dahin auf dieser höhe so und dann kommt
da mein kleiner ausgang nach draußen
aber der das ist doof das passt nicht
mit der tür das muss noch einen runter
irgendwie ihr euch mit ihr müsst auch
noch weggeben
doch es gibt auch so läuft wie soll ich
teste vorher gehabt diese krise lässt du
nicht bestimmte testobjekte der stirbt
jetzt bestimmt niemand kenne steht
derzeit schon froh so ward ihr kommt auf
weg da kommt nämlich auch wieder dieser
schöne schöne baum dingsbums mich gar
nicht mit simon beweise nicht aber ich
bin schon mit nach aufnahme deswegen
bringt gerade auch nicht so 345 mehr so
hier kommt wieder solche auch noch so
passt das überhaupt alle alle schade
schade
vielleicht sind sie einfach gerade nicht
so vorn
so wie mache ich das hier mit dem
eingang in den links oder soll ich den
relativ mittig halten
da soll ich denn wenn ich die mit ich
mache könnte man eigentlich hier fenster
aber das ist okay da hätte ich das mal
größer gebaut
ich hab zu hungern das ist unglaublich
das was macht überhaupt die deckel aus
cobbelsdorf nicht das finde ich in so
trübe
was kann ich denn sonst machen die
könnte er theoretisch aus dem anderen
holz machen oder das habe ich sonst noch
so ja wolle wäre natürlich geil aber dem
krieger so ist mein haus dann halt
direkt weg das wäre dann natürlich
wieder nicht so geil so ihr kommt damit
mir rein hier ein gold hab ich auch noch
auch man was mache ich denn mancher auf
manch ein jockey nein hawk i muss nun an
meine gäste weißt du möchtest wieder
raus spielen
man kann ich denn irgendwas geben komme
ich geb dir jetzt wissen sie ich
versuche weiter wie baue ich das jetzt
wie bei euch dann überhaupt das ab doch
erstmal das wisst ihr eigentlich genau
das gleiche sein wie hier das müsste ich
ja auch eigentlich eins runter nähe in
denen müsste gar nicht meine tür müsste
eigentlich sogar ins höher
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das allgemein
hier weitermachen möchte oder dieser
raum hier
ich glaube ich mache einfach hier ja
genau ich baue hier einfach noch sonne
raum dran das ist gut
dann habe ich dazu sonne trennwand aber
dies halt so trennwand mäßig wissen aber
scheint ich möchte dass er überall
schreibt unter allen videos die script
coni hat das geisterhaus coni hat auch
einfach das ganze wenn es fertig ist
macht ihr das weil das ist natürlich
noch nicht fertig dass es noch im rohbau
man sagt natürlich auch nicht vor bevor
man gekommen ist all das war geiler sex
sagt man ja auch nicht so ich brauche
noch ein bisschen cobblestone
habe ich nicht noch nicht so dann
könnten wir theoretisch auch schon mal
sand abfahren gehen und meine schaufel
erst mal kaputt ist ich weiß auch gar
nicht wie viel benutzung hat meine show
wohl noch vielleicht noch drei vier oder
drei so kommt die andere wieso kommt
nicht die andere kacke das immer artikel
bietet immer dann die andere schaufeln
kam auch mal wasser darf man noch ein
bisschen aufgeblasen glaube ich mich ins
wasser hier kann ich noch abbauen da da
da so immer schön weiter
ich meine das sind jetzt natürlich die
sachen ehe ich habe mir jetzt natürlich
kein thema vorbereitet ich quatsche es
mal ganz spontan über das quatschen weil
sie ja nicht nur irgendwas gerade
spontan zu es wird alle themen die wir
zu spontanen einfall von minecraft und
pcs und so zu tun aber wurden halt sind
halt alle schon ausgelutscht
ach so ich könnte euch ein paar
ankündigungen machen und zwar kommt das
geht ja gar nicht schließlich ist er
darunter stimmt kommt bald geht er
online zusammen mit was denkt die mit
dem mache ich das das ist auf jeden fall
ist es nicht aber die moderne play die
vielleicht ist sie manchmal dabei das
kann natürlich auch sein
nur ich habe zurzeit halt eine elgato
und die alligators echt kacke dafür weil
die alligators ohne verzögerung
irgendwie immer drin und das heißt quasi
dass ich mein bild zu spät sehe und dass
sie wegen dann erstmal die audiospur
wieder angleichen müssen das ganze
nochmal extrahieren blablabla dover
arbeit im leben eines katers
ich bin kein kater aber das halte der
hauptberuflich wollte schon sagen wir
fahren hier kann sie von außen gut
ankommen nach salz auf youtube deswegen
und fand ich das natürlich dann wie viel
grad
der ambler habe ich eigentlich ich mache
einfach dreist ex wollen dann müsste es
eigentlich reichen fliegen zum naschen
ich würde auch gern farbiges glas machen
aber nein wir spiele ich auf der 171
eine ältere version
es gibt auch keinen namen tags das
browser kann ihn leben browser heißen
wir machen uns einfach in unsere
gedanken rein dass der browser heißt ich
habe schon wieder gut ein bisschen erde
kann ich auch noch mit dem glaube ich
auch nicht so viel in poppelsdorf wollt
ihr auch noch holen
stimmt das einzige oder sind so viel
bieten einfach nur mein haus rum durch
mal mit unseren zweiten abschnitt ich
kann man eben ganz cook und der info
gold liegt ein bisschen show coupe oh no
das ist ein oder ist es einfach passiert
nichts der verspricht da macht das gar
nicht tablet pizza gibt immer auch nicht
gar nicht mehr
ich wollte ich mal weg das rose das ist
natürlich
trotzdem würde ich gern wissen ob wir
noch irgendwo das diamanten erstmal bei
der nachfolge sehen wie er sich gefreut
hat als er diamanten nicht mal ich habe
mehr als ein stack und das ist irgendwie
komisch
das ist hier so viel gibt aber manche
wirklich nichts finden legen wie das
halt immer sondern eine glückssache
kommt jetzt schwimmen filmbruder los
mayotte knapp unter den knapp so und
steine brauche ich auch noch weiter grad
in der höhle auch ich blöd man egal wenn
wir hier direkt zum stein quelle mehr
oder weniger
ich nenne es mal stein quelle und dann
mache ich da quasi so eine trennwand
rein auf die linke seite und auf die
andere seite mache ich dann
himmel klopfe ich schmeiße ich weg alter
babbel marburg cobblestone das ist ein
model koppel stone ich denke dann werde
ich die decke aus dabel machen oder
meinen boden auch ausgabe
obwohl dann passt es wieder nicht zum
rest kommt sondern das eigentlich auch
schon längst fällig obwohl es das ist
glaube ich sogar als boden oder den
nicht machen auf jeden fall näher ich
mach mit mabel als nabel oder stone ich
weiß es nicht
oder oder marvel stone oder back system
so kann ich mich noch ein bisschen ihr
dienst mitnehmen wochen eine knochen
klänge kommen zieht das ist für seine
urlaubs verbringen
eigentlich nicht durch seh schon das
wird die danach allerdings wäre ich dann
gleich nochmal eine aufnahme beendet
wenn nach wird wenn die noch gesagt die
verpennen gehen und wenn ich natürlich
noch im rennen gehen also das macht
jetzt noch eben so lange bis ich hier
keinen festen inventar habe dann hab ich
den keinen platz mehr
doch das nicht gut für euch parat haben
aber ich habe alles weggeschmissen so
hier um sie wieder raus hier aus leben
mitnehmen so das ist cool dass das alles
so wächst richtig geil kann ich zwar
meine fahne nicht mehr so richtig keit
hier dran bauen aber na gut ich weiß
auch gar nicht wie ich gerade im garten
brauch ich könnte auch eigentlich so
erst mal im garten lassen
also das ist jetzt natürlich alles
cobblestone hier muss man jetzt gucken
wie sich das entwickelt kommission kann
natürlich auch mal muss sie werden also
kann dann schon mal drauf kommen und so
natürlich nicht so schön von der pflege
her und so auch und sonst gleich geht
die sonne unter ich möchte dass sie noch
ganz kurz ebenso hier fertig machen komm
jetzt kommen
dann kann ich hier ich kann bis hier
muss dann wieder so ein komischer feiler
hin
wer hier 345 kommst du her einfach mal
komische quer banken kommt hier dann
wieder dahin muss auch gucken wie ich
das dann mit dem dach alles so verbinde
und so so da unten kommt cobblestone hin
weil ich ja viel zu wenig geholt oder
wie als ob ich nur ich habe da so ein
bisschen cobblestone geholt alter was
bin ich dann für schmuck soll dann
jedoch das richtig da kommt dann auch
glas wein und hier kommt ihr hin ich
setze meine fackel hin auch also das
wird dann quasi eine art nicht innenhof
aber es ist halt darauf monika ich
brauche dann eigentlich gar nicht hier
dicht komischen pfeiler du bist du ein
quasi komplett unnötig
dann brauche ich eigentlich auch gar
nicht diesen querbalken da oben aber ich
mache ich das denn dann sonnen ist außer
mit einem querbalken
ich kenne den querbalken theoretisch so
einfach lassen
ich muss er dann ein ich setze den
querbalken wirklich da oben so komplett
drüber
das kann ich natürlich machen weil dann
passt das da hinten wiederum bilden wir
du musst das war auf der anderen seite
auch wieder machen aber zurück damit ich
das dann hier quasi so machen kann so
und das ist es dann hier unsere
unterscheiden kann
red zusammen
so sind die 18 minuten 30 los los los
schreibt bettelt er jetzt nicht mehr
drin so denn ich möchte noch eben auf
der anderen seite ist dieses andere
dings acht kommen simon jetzt dann lege
ich jetzt hier auf der anderen seite
noch eben den hier
und hier auch dann kann ich nämlich hier
überlegen sind beim eingang nicht muss
erst mal rein
so aber ich finde es sieht eigentlich
ganz geil aus mein haus so ok meine
lieben freunde nämlich sagen wenn ich
das video jetzt hier in bettchen wenn es
euch gefallen da dürft ihr gerne einen
daumen hoch da lassen es wird mich auf
jeden fall sehr freund schreibt mir
weiterhin vorschläge hilfe mein haus in
die kommentare es sieht auf jeden fall
sehr geil aus ich finde das sehr geil
ich sagen sie muss man nächste mal
wieder rein zunächst mann und